hey i'm charles melton and i'm playing
teenage trivia
on the kelly clarkson show in high
school my best friends would describe me
as out of the box
funny charming sweet kind
they're just funny
the most memorable job i had as a
teenager was working at wendy's
for a year and a half and working at
arby's for six months
i would get a number i would get a
baconator number four
extra bacon extra cheese king-sized
fries
with all the sauces oh frosty frosty too
okay the last thing i texted my best
friend was ew
that's uh he sent me a picture of myself
most star struck i ever been was
i went to the nfl awards a couple years
ago and i met a bunch of nfl athletes
and i was pretty just
with alex i get really star struck
because that was my
journey to play in the nfl and sing for
you know athletes
i'm a philadelphia eagles fan i would
say my home state is kansas so i'm a
chiefs fan but i saw patrick mahomes
travis kelsey all those guys and i was
just like
i wanted to play in the nfl too
my guilty pleasure is ice cream after
midnight
because i don't feel guilty if it's
before midnight but if it's after
midnight
then i feel a little guilty uh i really
like pralines and cream
by haagen-dazs and uh i love
baskin robbins and i love ben and
jerry's
strawberry cheesecake is great caramel
core
chunky monkey's okay
my perfect partner is nata my dog
we do everything together and we're
gearing up to go on
our second year of road tripping
across america so that's gonna be fun
we'll go to yellowstone again i'm really
excited to go back to zion
zion in utah zion national park and
bryce canyon really excited to go back
to those places
thanks for playing along catch me on
kelly this week
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure